[موسيقى]
طب تم طابتها اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى اخبار
الساعه وهذه ابرز وعناوين
ازمه صامته بانتظار زياره رئيسيه ايران
تماطل بوعودها وتلوي ذراعه دمشق
بالتنازلات
واشنطن تلاحقوه في مصانع امريكا مكونات
الايرانيه وتصطدم باسواق الصين البعيده
افغانستان بعد الاحتجاجات الاستقالاتهم من
الجامعه ومناشدات بموقف دوليا حسن ضد
طالبان
العالم يطوي صفحه 2022 بحصيله دسمه
للكوارث الطبيعيه اخرها عاصفه القرن
والخبراء يحذرون من مناخ اسوء في عام 2023
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم على موقع ازمه الاقتصاديه يبحث
النظام السوري في اسباب تاخر الوعود
الايرانيه بانقاذ الوضع وعود قديمه لكنها
مؤجره
الاوسط وعود تتعلق بتامين طهران للنقل
ومشتقاته عبر 3 سفن تلك السفن لم تغادر
ايران ولم تصل سواحل سوريا حتى الان ازمه
المحروقات
بين البلدين والتي عادت الى السطح بعد
اعلان الرئيس الايراني عن زياره وشيءك الى
ابن جيراننا توفى من البرد وشاب فكيف ما
بدك اياني خاف على اولادي صغار ما يموتوا
من البرد
ضغوط مقابل تنازلات معادله بدات ايران
بارسائها مع حلفائها السوريين في دمشق
صحيفه الشرق الاوسط تكشف عن مماطله
ايرانيه بتامين النفطي للنظام ثلاث ناقلات
نفط ومشتقاته كانت ايران قد وعدت الاسد
قبل ثلاث سنوات بتامينها في خرق للعقبات
لكن الوعد ان لم يكتمل وافتعلت ازمه ضعفت
من ازمات السوريين اثر ارتفاعا غير مسبوق
في اسعار الوقود محدث شلل شبهتا بالخدمات
وارتفاع عن غير مسبوقا باسعار المحروقات
في يوليو الماضي تكرر طلب دمشق عبر وزير
الخارجيتها وتكررت ايضا المماطله
الايرانيه
وبحسب صحيفه الشرق الاوسط فان حيره سوريا
حول اسباب تاخر على عكس مجره العاده خلال
العقد الماضي بقيت مستمره الى ان حدث رهان
على زياره رئيس الى دمشق التي حدد موعدها
مبدايا وخلال الاعداد للزياره فوجئت دمشق
بسلسله من الطلبات ومساعدات الاتفاقات
وبدا الاخطر
حيث تضغط طهران بان تتم معامله الايرانيين
في اغلب المؤسسات الدوله كمعامله السوريين
وفي حال ارتكب ايرانيون جريمه فانهم
يحاكمون امام القضاء الايراني وليس امام
القضاء السوري
كما تضغط طهران لانتزاع ضمانات سياديه على
الاموال التي انفقتها دمشق فوجئت بعمق
المطالب وتهران فوجئت بالتراث السوري لكن
دبلوماسيا غربيه لفت الصحيفه الى ان ايران
تمارس ابتزازا لفرض هيمنتها كامله على
سوريا حتى لو كان على حساب السوري الذي
يموت من البرد او المتطور جوعان حنان
المصري العربيه
قد يتساءل البعض لماذا تضغط ايران على
دمشق الان صحيفه الشرق الاوسط نقلت عن
دبلوماسي الغربي زار سوريا اخيرا بان
طهران تستغل الازمه الاقتصاديه وتريد
الحصول على تنازلات سياديه كبيره في اوجه
دمشق لها حاليا وانشغال روسيا بحرب
اوكرانيا لسداد التكاليف التي دفعتها خلال
الحرب وتثبيت نفوذها لامد طويل
ساره السيد فايز اهلا بك يعني ايران ليس
مستغربا ان تطلبها هكذا طلبات فهي في موقع
قوه ولكن الترجي السوري
باعتقادك لماذا وهل لديها
دمشق خيارات اخرى
يعني يعني انا بعتقد انه
مشتريوس سوريين نظام الاسد عموما وليس
السوريين نظام الاسد عموما يطمح دائما في
كسب لحد النهائي
لذلك هو يتميز بهذا المعنى اما اما في
النهايه
فقد وضع كل اوراقي اصلا في سله ايران
ووضعها في في سله اخرى اقل اهميه مثل
الروسيه لكن هذه السله الايرانيه هي التي
قدمت كل سبل للحياه خلال 12 عاما
للنظام قدمت له المساعدات الماليه والنفط
وقدمت له الجيش قدمت اجهزه الامن والخبرات
والاسلحه والذخائر وكل شيء
اكثر من ذلك ايران
تسللت الى عمق المجتمع والدوله في سوريا
بمعنى ان ان النظام لا يمكن ان يقاوم
اليوم لو اراد لا يمكن ان يقاوم اليوم
الاخطار الايرانيه يوم يمكن ان يمثل تسلل
ايراني الى القرار السوري سوريا في سوريا
الايرانيين اقامه اليوم عصبه كبيره من
التشيع موجوده في ليس في دمشق فقط
ايران تريد هذه الاتفاقيه على غرار
الاتفاقيه الموقع بين نظام الاسد وروسيا
التي اعطتها ايضا دمشق الكثير
نعم نعم
ايران ايران تشعر اليوم بانها اصبحت
الورقه الرئيسيه
صادق فان كانت روسيا التغطيه الرئيسيه
لنظام الاسد لكن انشغال روسيا اليوم
بالحرب في اوكرانيا وتواجهه من صعوبات
داخليه
والدبلوماسي في الملف السوري ايران اليوم
تحاول بالفعل ان تملا الفراغ ذلك في تفرض
شروطها وتحصل على اقصى ما يمكن
نتوقف مع جانب من الاتفاقيات الاستراتيجيه
التي وقعتها ايران مع نظام الاسد في
السنوات الاخيره تتعلق احداها بعمل شركه
ايرانيه يدعمها الحرس الثوري الايراني
مشغلا ثالثا للهاتف الجوال اتفاقيه
لاستثمار الفوسفات السوري لمده 99
ااا 99 عاما ولا استحواذ على اراضي لاغراض
زراعيه وصناعيه بالاضافه الى اقامه بناء
نفطي على البحر المتوسط وتوقيع خط ائتمان
جديد من ايران بقيمه مليار دولار امريكي
يستخدم نصفه لتمويل تصدير نفط خام ومشتقات
نقيه اذن الى الكاتب سياسيه سوري فايس
ساره ما الذي حصل سيد فايز بكل هذه
الاتفاقيه
هذه الاتفاقيات طب يعني
تنظيمها عبر مجموعه من سنوات تتجاوز بعضها
عمره اكثر من خمس ست سنوات ليست هناك حتى
الان قدره على استثمار وتشغيل هذه
الاتفاقيات يعني اليوم حتى اليوم لا يمكن
لا يوجد موانئ سوريه تشتغل لا يمكن ان
تنقل همم او تستخرج نفط او مشتقات نفطيه
لا يمكن ان تقوم بعمليه تصفيه يعني لان
المصافي النفط الاثنتين في في في
حمص اعتداءتين عن العمل لا يمكن ان تشتغل
في مناجم الفوسفات حتى مناجم الفوسفات
اتفاقيه الفوسفات جرى انتقالها نقل بناء
على طلب روسي الى الروس لم تعود هذه
الاتفاقيه لصالح ايران طيب نقلها الى
الجانب الروسي لان الروس كانوا مصرين انه
ياخذوا هذه الاتفاقيه لهم همم
يعني يعني ايران عندها عندها اليوم
مش بس ايران كل المستثمرين الايرانيين
والروس وحتى الطامحين الاخرين في استثمار
في سوريا ليس لديهم اي فرصه
للقيام باستثمارات بسبب الوضع يعني كما هو
معروف
له وقود ولا كهرباء ولا ولا حتى ابونا
باختصار جدا اذا تكرمت وقت انتهى لكن هل
ستقدم سوريا وستقدم على هذه التنازلات
لصالح ايران ام لديها خيار اخر
يعني انا بعتقد انه النظام بما بما اعطاه
لايران في ال في المرحله السابقه وبما
صارت اليه ايران داخل
النظام وداخل المجتمع في سوريا
سيقدم كل هذه التنازلات خاصه وانه اختار
منذ البدايه اختار الحل العسكري الامني
الذي لا يوافق عليه في العالم احد غير
ايران
وحديثه الى الاخر شكرا جزيلا للكاتب
والسياسيه سوري في ساره من لندن شكرا
جزيلا لك يعطيك العافيه
[موسيقى]
الضغوط الايرانيه على دمشق وضعت على طاوله
النظام السوري خيارا اخر ليس ببعد عنها هو
المسار التركي التركي دخل على الخط عبر
موسكو ففي مؤشر على تطبيق
عقدت مباحثات ثلاثيه بين وزراء الدفاع
روسيا تركيا وسوريا اليوم في موسكو وهو
اللقاء الرسمي الاول بين مسؤولين سوريين
واثراك منذ 11 عاما وزراء الدفاع بحثه
الازمه السوريه ومشكلتي اللاجئين والارهاب
حسب ما اكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وزاره
الدفاع السوريه وصفت لقاء او وزراء الدفاع
الثلاثيه في موسكو بالايجابي
[موسيقى]
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
في ايران النظام يغري النواه الصلبه
بالامتيازات لقمع الاحتجاجات
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مع استمرار الاحتجاجات في
ايران طلبه وزير الخارجيه في ايطاليا
انطونيو فرجاني طلب ايران في وقت العنف ضد
المتظاهرين معتبرا عمليه القمع امرا غير
مقبول واموله وزير الخارجيه باعتماد طهران
طريق الحوار
الاعدام الصادره ضد المحتاجين واصفا بالخط
الاحمر
لكن السلطات الايرانيه لا تزال لا تضرب
بعرض الحائط كل التحذيرات الدوريه وتواصل
انتهاكاتها بل واغرت النواه الصلبه المخلص
لها بامتيازات كثيره للانضمام لحمله القمه
في ايران مع الاحتجاجات التي دشنت شهرها
الرابعه على انها تهديد الوجود
لذلك يلجا الى نواه صلبه موال يا رغم
اقليتها للحفاظ على الاسس التي قام عليها
عام
وفق تحقيق لصحيفه
هذا النظام تعتمد على الاف المواليد
المخلصين كحصن اساسيا ضد الاحتجاجات
ابرازهم الحرس الثوري والباسيج وميليشيات
المحليه اخرى هؤلاء الموالون استعنت بهم
السلطات الايرانيه لاخماد انتفاضه
المحتجين في الشوارع اضافه الى الدفاع عن
قيام الثوره الاسلاميه التي اسسها الخميني
لكن الولاء لا تضمنه العقائد فقط بل
الامتيازات اشارت صحيفه جورنال الى ان هذه
النواه المواليه الصلبه غالبا ما يكون
اعضائها من خلفيات المتواضعه اقتصاديا
ومحافظه اجتماعيه
ونضماني ولائها او تعزيزه يمنح النظام في
ايران امتيازات ووظائف واسلحه ويعطي
اولادهم افضليه التعليم في ابرز الجامعات
الايرانيه لكن كل ذلك غير كافي فقد حمل
استطلاع اجرته مؤسسه بحثيه غير الربحيه
تتخذ منه هولندا مقرا لها انباء سيئه
للسلطات الايرانيه وان كانت متوقعه لدى
اجهزه الاستخبارات اشار الاستطلاع الى ان
واحدا من اصل خمسه ايرانيين يدعمون النظام
الحالي
مؤشر يبرر قلق السلطات الايرانيه
ويعزز فرقه المحتجين
[تصفيق]
في مزيد من انتهاكات النظام الايرانيه
ايضا انطلقت محطه ايران انترناشونال
تقارير تفيد بان عناصر تابعه للاستخبارات
والحرس الثوري الايراني هاجمت منازل عدد
من الصحفيين وصادرت اجهزتهم الالكترونيه
واضافت التقارير ان عناصر النظام الايراني
هددت الصحفيين بالاعتقال والسجن في حال تم
نشر اي محتوى او ابداء راي شخصي حول اوضاع
المعتقليله في الاحتجاجات او اجراء مقابله
مع اسريهم
[موسيقى]
ايران تشغل العالم بما يجري في الداخل
وبينشطتها في الخارج ايضا فالمسيرات
الايرانيه تخلق ازمه تمتد من امريكا وصولا
الى اوكرانيا عبر روسيا فهي باتت صداعا في
راس الولايات المتحده سيما وان مكونات هذه
المسيارات مكونات امريكيه مهربه تستخدم في
صناعه هذه المسيرات واشنطن تريد ان تضع
حدا لهذه المسيارات وهذا ما كشفت عنه
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز التي قالت بان
الاداره الامريكيه تبذل جهودا كبيرا للحد
من قدره ايران على انتاج وتسليم المسيارات
الى روسيا والتي تستخدمها ضد اوكرانيا
وتشير التقارير الى ان طهران زودت القوات
الروسيه حتى الان بنحو 1700 طائره هجوميه
بدون طيار
وتخطط لتزويدها ب 300 اخرى في المستقبل
القريب
ملف المسيرات الايرانيه باتا مصدر ازعاج
حقيقي للولايات المتحده التي كانت فتحت
تحقيقا بخصوص تهريب المكونات الغربيه شبكه
سي ان ان قالت الى ان ايران تجد وفره من
التكنولوجيا المتاحه تجاريا على الرغم من
فضل عقوبه صارمه عليها كما ان هذه
المكونات المستخدمه لا تقتصر فقط على تلك
الشركات او التي تنتجها الشركات الامريكيه
حيث تم العثور على مكونات مصنعه في بلدان
اخرى مثل البطاريات يابانيه ومحرك نمساوي
[موسيقى]
بعد ما ظلت ساحه الحرب بالمسرحا نقل
الكثير من الخطط العسكريه رجعت في الايام
الاخيره حديث عن خطط سلام لانهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا لكن هذه تلميحات تجد الابواب دون
صدى امامها في ظل تشبت كل طرف بشروط غير
قابله للتفاوض اوكرانيا التي تستعد لعفري
قمه السلام في الذكرى الاولى للعمليه
العسكريه الروسيه قدمت قطط استعراضتها او
استعرضت فيها شروطها لتحقيق السلام التي
لم تاتي باي جديد بخصوص نقاط النزاع مع
موسكو فما كان للاخيره الا ان ابدت رفضا
كليا لهذه الخطه
الله كريم لان اوضح ايضا اسباب رفضه لهذه
لهذا المقترح حيده شدد على ان اي مقترحات
اللي انهاء الصراع في اوكرانيا يجب ان
تاخذ في عين الاعتبار حقائق اليوم في ما
يتعلق بالمناطق الاوكرانيه الاربعه التي
اعلنت روسيا ضمها اليها مؤخرا وهذه هي
عقبه الحل طبعا ذلك يتعارض معه كليا مع
شروط كيب التي تؤكد على ضروره استعاده
وحده الاراضي الاخرانيه كما كان عليه
الحال قبل العمليه العسكريه
[موسيقى]
خلال الحرب في اوكرانيا فان سباق تسلحها
بلغ اشده بين الجانبين الذين يتبادلان
الاتهامات بهذا بخصوص الموضوع لا يستثني
اي نوع من الاسلحه حتى الرقميه منها
النائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي
في تزويد اوكرانيا في اسلحه الرقميه بشكل
لا يمكن السيطره عليه وهو امر محفوف
المخاطره على العالم باسره على حد قوله
اضاف المسؤول الروسي ان عدد الهجمات
الالكترونيه على روسيا في عام 2022 ارتفع
بنسبه 80% وتحديدا منذ بدايه العمليه
العسكريه على اوكرانيا
الاسلحه الرقميه هي عباره عن برامج
الكترونيه متطوره تسمح بتعطيل او اختراق
بيانات مؤسسات حكوميه او غيرها بالاستعانه
بقراصنه الكترونيين اه بشكل عام فان الهدف
الرئيسي للهجمات الالكترونيه الاوكرانيه
كانم المؤسسات الماليه فضلا عن مرافق
البنيه التحتيه للمعلومات الحيويه
والمؤسسات ذات الاهميه الاجتماعيه
[موسيقى]
تحركات المدنيه داخل افغانستان احتجاجا
على قيود طالبان ضد المراه فمع خروج
تظاهرات نسائيه في انحاء البلاد قدم 13
استاذا جامعيا بينهم سبعه من النساء
استقالتهم من جامعتك الله ردا على قرار
طالبان باغلاق الجامعه امام الفتيات ولم
تستسلم النساء للقرار بينما يحاولنا
مواجهه الطالبان بالاستقاله والتظاهرات
نشدت ناشطات افغانيات المجتمع الدولي
اتخاذ خطوات فاعله للضغط على الحركه
لم تمنعها قراره حركه طالبان بحق المراه
من المثابره كغيرها من الفتيات منعت باغشي
المحاضره الجامعيه الافغانيه من مواصله
مهام التدريس لتبقى حديثه المنزل وسط
كتبها واوراق العمل التي تابى ان تطوى
كصفحات الماضي
او انسانيه بموجب المرسوم الجديد لا يمكن
للمراه ان تواصل واجباتها وانشطتها
وبالتالي لم يعد للمراه مكان في افغانستان
وهذا امر مخيب للاعمال
بين جدران منزلها تحاصر خيبه الامل
المحاضره الافغانيه لكنها تنتظر انفراجه
قد تاتي من خلال ضغوط ومناشدات المجتمع
الدوليه
على عدم التخلي عن المراه الافغانيه
ونسيانها يجب عدم معاقبه النساء
الافغانيات بعد الان ويجب عدم الحكم عليهن
بالسجن
اما اشكال حصار النساء في المجتمع
الافغاني فتتزايد يوما بعد الاخر دوريات
المسلحه من قبل اعضاء الحركه المتطرفه في
الشوارع تواجهها اصوات نساء تمردنا على
رجعيه السياسات طالبا
علي السمان العربي
[موسيقى]
خيل اهلا بك دكتور يعني هذه الاستقالات
كيف ستؤثر على قرار حركه طالبان
[تصفيق]
جاكي شان
الاحتجاجات المدنيه التي يقوم بها اكثر من
75 من المعلمين استقالوا هذه اضرابات
ولكنها لن تؤثر على الحكومه الراهنه طيب
ايضا النساء يخرجن في هذه الاحتجاجات
يطالب من المجتمع الدولي بتقديم او
بالتمديد وكذلك فرض اجراءات صارمه على
طالبا لكن هل سيجدي ذلك نفعل
تقدير الفراوله
[موسيقى]
على انه يمكن ان يوقف مكتبهم في الدوحه او
وضع اييه
عقوبات من سيتاثر
من الشعب ان يتظاهر ويطالب بحقوقكم لكن
نحن في الشتاء والشعب فقير جدا
وكثر كانوا معتقلين
ومعتقلين حتى النساء الحقيقيات معتقلات
لذلك هناك خوف بين افراد الشعب الا انها
الغالبيه في هذا الموسم الشتاء لا يمكن ان
يخرج
لان الشباب الشباب
يخرجون يخرجون وليله امس كانوا يحتاجون
بالشوارع طيب يعني مثل هذا القرار ما الذي
تريد الحركه هل يعش شعب الافغاني ماذا
تريد الحركه من خلال هذا القرار وهكذا
اجراءات
الشعب
[موسيقى]
مقابله همم
تحدث عن المساله وقال ان الفتيات ياتينا
من القرى وياتينا يقطعنا المسافات وليس
لديهن لديهم محرم معهم همم
هناك مساله عدم ارتداء الحجاب والبرقع همم
وقالوا ان التعليم مختلط ولا يريدون
التعليم المختلطه
بالرغم ان هناك
همم منفصله في الجامعات الا ان هذا اشهر
الشعب بالاحباط
الشعب يريد لبناته ان يتعلمنا بالم باريس
والجامعات وفي فصول للفتيات الا ان الشعب
ليس لديه
السلطه
ولا يستطيعون الا ان يعربوا عن همم عدم
موافقتهم ويحتاجون ويقولوا ان حقهم هو
تعليم بناتهم لكن للاسف هذا ليس ممكن وفي
كابل وفي المحافظات اخرى همم الامتحانات
انتهت
وهمم والان فصل الشتاء حتى اذا هناك اجازه
والتحدث عن طريقه من الشريعه وطريقه همم
موثوقه دينيه للخروج من المشكله لكن الشعب
لا يثق بذلك بل يريدون للشعب ان يرتاح
لهذه المساله ويجلسون تضعها
يا دكتور
شكرا جزيلا لك كنت معنا من كابول
[موسيقى]
في الصين عادت عدا كورونا لترتاح البلاد
متسببه في ازمه حقيقيه داخل لها
المستشفيات المرافق الطبيه في الصين بدات
تكافح لمواجهه الزياده الكبيره في عذاب
مرضى كوبرد الغناء يتزايدون منذ ان علقت
بكين القيود المفروضه لمواجهه هذا الوباء
فلول مره منذ بدايه الجائحه اواخر سنه
2019 الغت البلاد مجموعه من الاجراءات
التي اتخذت من اجل مواجهه هذا الوباء مثل
الاختبارات الجماعيه وعمليات الاغلاق
المشاهد فيها من المستشفيات الصينيه تعكس
معركه قاسيه ياخذها الاطباء هناك
[موسيقى]
في حكومه الجديده قدما نتنياهو تنازلات
كبيره ومنها سلطات النواه صلاحيه غير
مسبوقه لشركائه من اليمين المتطرف يحملون
ايديولوجيات عن سوريا
الحقائب الوزاريه الوازنه لحكومه نتنياهو
الناشئه وقعت في قبضه متطرفين يحملون
ايديولوجيات عنصريه يقول الاسرائيليون ان
استسلام ناتن يهوبات واضحا خاصه على
الصعيد الامني بعد منحه سلطات واسعه
لشريكيه بتليلس مودريتش وتمر بني كبير
القسام داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي هذه
الكتله حقيقه وان كان تتمسح بالصهيونيه هي
ليست كذلك لا تؤمن بالقيم التي اسست عليها
الحركه الصهيونيه
المساواه بين الرجل والمراه بين المواطنين
بين مكونات الشعب داخل اسرائيل
منصبه وزير الامن القومي و سيمنح السيطره
المباشره على حارس الحدود بحيث يكون قادرا
على التاثير على التعليمات للقوات
بتوفير الحصانه للجنود والشرطه
الاسرائيليه لاطلاق النار والذي اعتبره
الفلسطينيون اعطاء الجنود تصريحا غير
محدودا للقتل
لا شك في انه اسرائيل اليوم امام مواقع
غريب وغير مضبوط حيث انه مجموعه من
المتطرفين الذين لم يخدموا بالجيش انا جيش
حقيقه لم يتقبلهم بسبب ماضيهم المشاهب في
صباهم يريدون التحكم في المؤسسه العسكريه
واملائه جدتهم المتطرفه والعنصريه على على
الجيش وقوى الامن
الدينيه سيتولى منصب وزيرا في وزاره الامن
وسيطر على الاداره المدنيه وسيكون تعزيز
وتوسيع الاستيطان وتهجير مزيدا من العرب
من اولوياته
على ما يبدو حكومه نتنياهو الناشئه ستؤدي
الى فوض داخليه وتاكلي دعم الناخبين
العلمانيين لحزب اليكود اضافه لتفجير
الوضع الميداني في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
وافسادهم طبقه من علاقات بين اسرائيل
والسلطه الفلسطينيه لان كل غاصي من القدس
العربيه
[موسيقى]
الذين ايضا في اخبار الساعه
عاصفه القرنه بعد الثلوج تحذيرات من
السيول
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله الولايات المتحده تتاهب للخروج
من عاصفه القرن المميته لكن غضب الطبيعه
يبدو مستمرا في خدمه الارصاد الجويه
الامريكيه توقعت ان يتغير الموقف جبريا
بدوبان سريع للثلوج في وقت لاحق هذا
الاسبوع مع ارتفاع درجات الحراره لمستويات
الربيعيه اعلى بكثير من درجه التجمد
مصحوبه بامطار قد تسبب سيول وفيضانات
وتسابق السلطات الزمن من اجل تكثيف عمليات
ازاله الثلوج للسماح بتصريف المياه
الناتجه عن الذوبان تحسبا لكارثه اخرى
[موسيقى]
هذه العاصفه الثلجيه التي لم تشهد
الولايات المتحده منذ نحو 45 عاما وما
ينتظرها من فيضانات بالاضافه الى ما تشهده
الكثير من بقاع العالم من كوارث طبيعيه
كلها تتبعنا لالقاء نظره عن قرب على اثار
التغير المناخي التي عاصفت بكوكبنا هذا
العام وما ينتظرنا العام المقبل التقارير
غير مبشرا بما هو قادم خبراء المناخ
توقعوا ان يكون العام المقبل واحدا من
اكثر الاعوام سخونه على مستوى العالم على
الاطلاق التقارير ترجح ان يكون متوسط
درجات الحراره العالميه اعلى بناحو 1.2
درجه مئويه مما كان عليه في اوقات ما قبل
الثوره الصناعيه الامور قد تسوق اكثر
واكثر بالنسبه لسخونه الارض اذا استمر
ارتفاعا انبعاثات الغازات الدفيئه عالميا
وافقه الخبراء
وحتى لا نشهد المزيد من الكوارث الطبيعيه
لابد من اتخاذ قرارات مهمه وفي اسرع وقت
للسيما مع تحذيرات
المتخصص بعلوم المناخ روبير افاتار الذي
قال ان هذه الكوارث التي شاهدناها في
العام 2022 مجرد البدايه فالامور قد
تتصاعد على نطاق اوسع مستقبلا عموما دعونا
نلقي نظره على ابرز الكوارث الطبيعيه التي
شهدها هذا الكوكب في هذا العام
[موسيقى]
الدكتور حسان التليلي المتخصصه في التنميه
وسياسات البيئيه ينضم الينا من باريس
دكتور اهلا بك يعني اوروبا ليست استثناءا
الولايات المتحده هذا الكوكب في هذا العام
شهيد الكثير 2023
هل نتوقع اسوا
الواقع ان
الهيئه الدوليه التي تعنى بالتغير المناخي
في مختلف التقارير التي تصدرها ومختلف
المنظمات وهيئات الارصاد الجويه تتوقع كما
ذكرتم قبل قليل من ان عام 2000 و 2023
سيكونوا اسوا من عام 2000
و22 فيما يتعلق بدرجات درجات ارتفاع درجات
الحراره بشكل غير معهود ومرد ذلك بطبيعه
الحال الى ما يسمى الظواهر المتطرفه او
الظواهر المناخيه القصوى التي حصلت هذا
العام في تقريبا في كل قارات العالم حصلت
في استراليا حصلت في القاره الامريكيه
حصلت في اوروبا حصلت في افريقيا وتمثلت
اساسا في ظاهرتين اثنتين ظاهره ال ال ال
يعني القيظ الذي يولد جفاف مسبوق ثم ظاهره
ال ال السيول التي تنزل بسرعه فتتحوس
فتتحول في ساعه او ساعتين الى فيضانات همم
فعلا عام 2022 طيب التقارير تتوقع ان
تستمر او تحتدي بس هذه الظواهر وليس ذلك
بالامر الجديد الدكتور يعني اليوم همم
هناك ايضا تخوفات من ان يح- تحدث فيضانات
في همم الولايات المتحده تسونامي كنا
نراها في دول شرق اسيا هل من الممكن ان
يتغير الوضع ويكون في اماكن اخرى في
العالم
طبعا التسونامي يعني عاده هناك عده بعض
المناطق التي يحصل فيها تسونامي يعني
منطقه المحيط الهندي
ومنطقه معرضه لكثير من هذه الظاهره ولكن
خبراء المناخ ولا سيما اللجنه الدوليه
التي تعلب التغير المناخي تؤكد منذ سنوات
عديده ان هناك مناطق اخرى منها المنطقه
المتوسطيه المنطقه المتوسطيه ومنظمه
اليونسكو تعمل منذ سنوات على اليه جديده
وتؤكد يوما بعد اخر ان التهيؤ الى مثل هذه
التسوناميات لا ينبغي ان ياتي عبر الحديث
عنها فقد بر- عبر تمارين يقوم بها السكان
انفسهم وتقوم بها هيئات الدفاع المدني مع
السلطات المحليه والصيطان الوطنيه
اسالك منطقتنا كيف كيف الامر او التنبؤ
لها العام المقبل ما الذي من الممكن ان
يحدث يعني بالكويت مثلا توصل لدرجه
الحراره تلامس سقف الستين صيفا بالام
شهدنا تساقط لبعض الثلوج او البرد
نعم يحصل هذا يعني
التقلبات الجويه المفاجئه التي مثل ما
ذكرت انت فالت قبل قليل في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه كانت هناك عواصف ثلجيه
وكان هناك تجمد للجليد فالان الضغط الجوي
السريع يؤدي الى
يؤدي الى انخفاض او ارتفاع في الدرجات
الحراره بثلاثين درجه في بعض الاحيان فقد
تنخفض درجات الحراره وقد ترتفع اذا انخفضت
كثيرا تولد ثلوج واذا ارتفعت ولكن الغالب
هو الارتفاع بالنسبه للمنطقه العربيه مثلا
دول مثل الكويت مثل العراق دول الخليج دول
الخليج ماساه تعاني في المستقبل من قصه
يعني ارتفاع درجات الحراره ثم قصه الرطوبه
وبالتالي المشكله الصحيه ستطرح بحده دي
رغم ان بلدان الخلي تستطيع ان تتكيف بشكل
افضل من ما هي عليه الحال بالنسبه لاوروبا
الغربيه لانها تعرف هذه الظاهره منذ عقود
واستعدت لها شيئا فشيئا الان بالنسبه
للسنه المقبله هناك تخوف كبير في المنطقه
المتوسطيه الشماليه من ان تحتد يحتد القيض
وان تزيد عدد الوفيات المبكره بسبب فترات
القيض غير المعوده وفعلا هذا هذه مخاوف
لدى منظمه الصحه العالميه ولد وزارات
الصحه في بلدان اوروبا الغربيه شكرا جزيلا
الدكتور حسان التلايله المتخصص في التنميه
والسياسات البيئيه يعني ان شاء الله نتمنى
تكون همم 23 تكون خفيف شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
هذه وقفه مع ابرز احداث سبتمبر هذا العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
محمد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في نهايه النشره هذا تذكرهم بابرز
العناوين
ازمه صامته بانتظار زياره رئيسيه ران
تماطل بوعودها وتلوي ذراع دمشق بالتنازلات
واشنطن تلاحقون في مصانع امريكا مكونات
المسيارات الايرانيه وتصطدم باسواق الصين
البعيده
في افغانستان بعد الاحتجاجات استقالاتهم
من الجامعات ومناشدات بموقف الدولي حسن ضد
طالبان
العالم يطوي صفحه 2022 بحصيله دسمه
للكوارث الطبيعيه اخرها عاصفه القرن
والقرب الخبراء يحذرونا من مناخ اسوا في
العام القادم
شكرا لكم المتابعه في امان الكريم
[موسيقى]